casi un año de pandemia y la cultura
sigue siendo una sonrisa con fuerzas
milenarias como canta el argentino león
gieco a un mal herida espera que el
tiempo le ilumine otra vez el alma
[Música]
el vacío visto el silencio del teatro
bogotano petra que hoy nos acoge son la
punta del mayor bloqueo que han vivido y
todavía viven las industrias culturales
en una frase esta ha sido el gran golpe
del virus en el sector que jamás
olvidará estos diez tarantines cos meses
resumirlos es irreal el cierre y la
cancelación o postergación de eventos de
tono en seguida todas las cadenas y
procesos y ahí de forma masiva artistas
e instituciones y grupos sostuvieron la
actividad con un esfuerzo creativo en
balcones y online que amplió la estética
del arte se consumieron muchos bienes
culturales muchos compañeros generaron
contenidos desde los balcones y sus
casas
creo que los músicos y todos los
artistas en general fueron
actores valga la redundancia
imprescindibles para sobrellevar
arrendamiento saben cómo ha sido y está
siendo esta reclusión y para la cultura
desde el mismo trauma la de europa luego
de china reabrió relativamente pronto
aunque muchos como los teatros list
walls hoy no pudieron hasta septiembre y
fue sin garantías porque un segundo
cierre en vistió los planes con francia
retrasando los hasta enero
aún más difícil lo ha tenido
latinoamérica experimentó un único y
largo confinamiento con uruguay y las
librerías y los museos de la región a la
cabeza de la descarada el coste de
volver la otra estética la de los
protocolos
[Música]
i
antes que nada fabio codirector de petra
junto a marcela valencia muchísimas
gracias para arroparnos en vuestro
teatro le pusiste el cierre un 14 de
marzo en medio de una obra y luego lo
habéis alumbrado de nuevo en octubre
cómo ha sido ese cierre y qué ha
significado para vosotros igual que a
todo el mundo fue terrible porque
teníamos estamos en nuestro mejor
momento teníamos una obra emblemática
nuestra que llama la vida de liebre
teníamos toda la boletería gota de marzo
parte de abril las cuotas con el banco
porque esta casa la estamos pagando las
teníamos cubiertas y teníamos cubierto
para pagar tres meses más entonces
estábamos en un muy buen momento que un
grupo de teatro diga que está en un muy
buen momento económico es tres especies
histórico y nos tocó cerrar entonces
tocaba hacer la limpieza pero éste y
recorrer este teatro vacío durante meses
porque viene todo casi todos los días
venía
y recordé el teatro durante meses era
durísimo ver la escenografía montada a
vestuario los camerinos tal cual como lo
han dejado los actores del último día
era como si el mundo hubiera
desaparecido y uno se hubiera quedado
solo
sin embargo empezamos a hacer un montón
de cosas empezamos a hacer cosas
audiovisuales cosas con tintes de humor
alrededor de la pandemia empezamos a
hacer un podcast empezamos a trabajar
sobre otras obras de teatro empezamos a
pasar proyectos nunca nunca se logró el
nivel que llevábamos pero logramos
mantenernos ahí y mantener sobre todo la
nómina acá el teatro se les siguió
pagando a todos los empleados algunos al
50% otro 75% como ha sido volver al
teatro petra con un aforo 20 25% y
además que esas medidas esos protocolos
conllevan un gasto también desde desde
el momento en que en que cerramos
nuestro jefe técnico delio leyva dijo
preparémonos por si acaso entonces él se
inventó como unos acrílicos aquí atrás
para separar una
gente con otra luego nos dimos cuenta
que sólo estaban haciendo en holanda a
mí lo que más me preocupaba era el que
se viera frío lejano triste entonces la
idea era poner lo bonito que fuera un
ambiente seguro pero bonito y extremar
las medidas de seguridad para que la
gente si alguien llega y le molesta que
uno agrega lávese las manos afuera
tómese la temperatura hcg mantenga el
tapabocas tapa boca y nariz si a alguien
le molesta eso puede que le moleste en
ese momento pero va a decir en ese sitio
es seguro
en ese sitio me cuidado eres dramaturgo
y cineasta también este escritor como
fue para ti es decir bienvenidos al
teatro petra la primera vez no tras el
regreso que todavía se me quiera las
ojotas lo que más le gusta decir antes
de empezar funciones hace siete meses no
podíamos decir esto
bienvenidos a teatro
[Música]
estás sobre tablas también es insólito
para nosotros sobre todo cuando la
virtualidad cultural que ya era fuerte
en youtubers galerías y museos ha
completado en 2020 su consagración otro
tanto para el coronavirus que se ve
clarísimo en lo literario el panorama
editorial es incierto y se ha
reorganizado reduciendo publicaciones y
eligiendo novedades y reimpresiones
seguras pero se ha expandido en su forma
las librerías han abrazado la venta web
y a domicilio los symbol así como las
charlas en streaming han aumentado
mientras que las ferias ya han hecho
suyo el modelo híbrido la feria de
guadalajara tuvo que cambiar su dinámica
laboral de 33 años para controlar 406
actos online un experimento que dependió
de la conexión y sonido de los invitados
que no generó ganancia pero él acercó a
21 millones de personas de 84 países
muchas primerizas en una feria fue todo
para nosotros experimental con mucho
éxito y muchos triunfos pero no dejó de
ser experimental tenemos que analizar
cómo equipo hacia dónde vamos que
podemos incorporar de lo virtual pero
que tenemos que retomar
para que en noviembre de 2021 regresemos
a una feria presencial que será un
control sanitario lo más seguro es decir
hay muchas cosas que ya llegaron para
quedarse pero como gente que organizó un
evento masivo
tenemos que tomarlo en cuenta así y
tendremos que tomar en cuenta también
todo lo bueno que nos dio llegar a
lugares tan remotos y a gente que nunca
había podido venir a la feria que eso es
lo que principalmente nos dice la gente
para marisol todo esto es una gran obra
de ficción terrorífica la cultura
resiliente como es no las teme pero no
esconde su cansancio y no puede obviar
que la pandemia ha profundizado la
precariedad de sus más de 30 millones de
trabajadores en el mundo hablamos de una
crisis que no puede agarrarse de lo
digital y daña a todos desde músicos y
técnicos hasta bailarines y artistas
callejeros de los peor parados los
eventos masivos
2020 ha desbancado a 2008 el título de
peor crisis para el sector en dos meses
la pandemia precarizó a los
profesionales e hizo temer cierres
definitivos tras diez la unesco ya
cuenta por millones los empleos perdidos
en cifras globales en torno a 10
millones pertenecen a la industria del
cine
del lado editorial el mercado registra
una caída del 75 por ciento mientras que
seis meses de parón musical han supuesto
unos diez mil millones de dólares menos
en patrocinios numerosos gobiernos han
otorgado subsidios e incrementado
presupuestos pero en pocos países ha
bastado para cubrir una cultura formada
por un 90% de pymes y una mayoría de
autónomos cuyas economías dependen de
proyectos intermitentes sobre todo los
sectores cinematográfico teatral de
danza circo y música desde broadway
hasta el west end londinense pasando por
espectáculos y conciertos llevan sin
abrir desde marzo cero ingresos que en
muchos casos están traduciendo en
necesidades alimentarias más o menos
trabajadores a lo largo del país sea mi
músico
no están volviendo al trabajo a los 2
meses de la pandemia nosotros empezamos
a asistir compañeros empezamos primero
se serían 500 y después hoy en día el
número los decía estamos repartiendo más
de 12 toneladas de alimentos y estamos
al límite operativo de nuestra
organización el ser masivos o que el
aforo reducido le salga pérdida no les
ha afectado tanto como ver que la
cultura ha sido cerrada varias veces y
en todas ha sido última en abrir
no olvidamos cómo seguía la canción de
gieco porque tiene razón pesa todo pese
a lo lírico la cultura se queda aquí y
este encierro ha engendrado un sinfín de
variantes artísticas alimentadas por las
plataformas y las redes jorge carrión es
nuestro guía final en la certeza de que
lo analógico y lo viral han consolidado
su unión dando paso a otra era cultural
la cultura cambia y es cambio pero la
pandemia ha acelerado su mutación dicho
en meme así iba encaminada y así es
ahora en un inicio el hobbit 19 le dio a
la nostalgia recuperando el coche como
vía para volver a los cines un clásico
que ha derivado en auto concierto auto
circo auto arte y hasta auto dramaturgia
si no fuera por el virus ni siquiera
hubiéramos pensado en estas formas de
actuación de somos gone coffin line el
espectáculo debe continuar con kobe 25
beat como creadores nuestro trabajo es
crear una nueva normalidad previo a esta
una casa podría ser el escenario de una
obra hoy las actuaciones también se
sirven para llevar con malabares desde
una ventana y exposiciones de arte tras
dos escaparates de restaurantes y
tiendas en la realidad aumentada en la
que vivimos al museo se va vía instagram
sin que tenga versión física mientras
que a los de toda la vida se puede ir
siendo un robot con reflejo y voz
propios ciertas hibridaciones y metas
disciplinas serán temporales pero hay
formatos que no tienen retorno como el
de las series
que se escuchan en podcast como las
obras con lenguaje audiovisual o
difundido por streaming y como los
conciertos en videojuegos o youtube las
plataformas y las redes son las grandes
portadoras de esta nueva cultura
explorada por jorge carrión no sólo la
atestigua con el ensayo sonoro solaris o
curarnos una revista por whatsapp sino
que en plena viralidad biológica ha
naturalizado la viralidad digital
para carrión nuestras vidas tienen un
pie en lo clásico y lo viral igual que
los objetos culturales la cultura
clásica y la viral no sólo conviven
fuera de la pantalla en la vida de los
lectores sino que también convive en la
pantalla porque finalmente un vídeo de
youtube o un podcast de ficción tiene
una genética que nos lleva al cine a la
radio al teatro etcétera todos estamos
ahora entre esos dos mundos con más
consciencia o con menos conciencia las
redes sociales yo diría que han llegado
para quedarse y que por tanto cualquier
creador
tiene que encontrar su pacto personal
con ellas este año la cultura se ha
visto muy afectada pero también muy
transformada y ha servido reflexiones
sobre la venta inédita de obras
museísticas el estreno simultáneo en
cines y streaming y su carácter esencial
para nosotros la cultura ha salvado 2020
para gobiernos como el alemán o el
mexicano es esencial pero lo esencial se
decide en cada uno si hace parte de su
bienestar
este 2021 consuma cultura el miedo es
legítimo pero el sector que vive de lo
social es muy seguro y requiere de apoyo
y presupuestos dignos gracias a teatro
petra por el espacio a nuestros
invitados por sus voces y a ustedes por
seguirnos cuídense mucho muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]